لم نر مثل هذا من قبل
طوال فترة وجودنا هنا ،
هذا ما يبدو عليه كوفن 19 في
كاليفورنيا في عام 2021
منظر من الجحيم كان عدد القتلى
خارج هذا العالم على حافة
صحراء موهافي في
مستشفى سانت ماري الطبي  مركز في وادي التفاح ،
يمكنك رؤية الأزمة
حتى قبل أن تمشي ، احتفظ بهذا الأمر في
أنفك جيدًا ،
يصل المرضى باستمرار ، بعضهم بواسطة
سيارة الإسعاف
، يصل فريق إضراب من الحرس الوطني في كاليفورنيا من الأطباء والممرضين
يوميًا ، هذه منطقة ذات
حاجة
كبيرة ونحن سعداء  لأكون هنا كما تعلم
عندما دخلت إليه لأول مرة ، شعرت وكأنه ربما أداة
إسعافات أولية على نزيف شرياني
تدفق المرضى الذين لن يتوقفوا ،
سأقول أن حوالي 80 بالمائة من مرضانا
مغطاة بجدران بلاستيكية مؤقتة
أقيمت
كلها  فوق هذا المستشفى ، قم بإنشاء متاهة من
المرضى الذين يعانون من حالات طوارئ أخرى على طول
القاعات ، حيث يمتلئ المستشفى هنا لدرجة أن
بعض المرضى الذين ترونهم
هنا في الممرات
سيضطرون إلى الانتظار من سبعة إلى عشرة أيام
ربما
لمجرد الحصول على  غرفة يحتاجون إلى
إدخالها إلى المستشفى
ولكن يتم الاعتناء بهم في
الممرات في الوقت الحالي
في الطابق العلوي في 20 سريرًا وحدة العناية
المركزة في وحدة العناية المركزة ، ونرى الموت والموت بشكل يومي ولكن لا يصل هذا المقياس مطلقًا إلى كل
سرير في وحدة العناية المركزة
كل موظف مشغول بإنقاذ
المرضى
لدينا أكثر من 50 مريضًا في وحدة العناية المركزة في
المستشفى في الوقت
الحالي ولدينا فقط الطاقم للعناية
بحوالي 20 منهم ،
لذلك يتم الضغط علينا ،
يتم دفع الممرضات إلى نقاط الانهيار المطلقة
وبعد ذلك قليلاً  علاوة على ذلك ، كل يوم
،
هناك سلسلة لا تنتهي من رموز التصفير
ومكالمات الاستجابة السريعة التي
تنبه الموظفين عندما يتوقف قلب شخص ما
أو يتوقف التنفس ،
وهذا ما يحدث خلف هذه
الستارة داخل وحدة الطمع التي تم إنشاؤها حديثًا والتي
لا يستطيع مريض طمع 19 في الألم.  التقطت
أنفاسها
لا تستطيع الممرضات والأطباء العمل
كل يوم لإرهاق
الخسائر الجسدية بالطبع هناك أيضًا
خسائر عاطفية ومن الصعب جدًا
رؤية كل هؤلاء المرضى يموتون
هل تعلم أن معدل الوفيات
مرتفع جدًا جدًا ، كيف
تتعامل مع هذا ، أعني هل أنت بخير
أعتقد أنني ما زلت واقفة ولكن
هل تعلم أننا سنرى سأعطيها بضعة
أشهر ولكن
الآن مريض  يحتاج إليه ، إنه على جهاز
الإنعاش القلبي الرئوي في حالة تعرضه للهجوم ،
حيث انهارت رئته ،
هناك تدافع لإدخال أنبوب صدري
، والفرق بين الحياة والموت ،
لا يأخذ الأشخاص النحيفون الأمر على
محمل الجد حتى يكونون هنا معنا
أو حتى '  re على السطر الآخر من
تلك المكالمة الهاتفية ، التحدث إلى أفراد أسرتهم
للمرة الأخيرة ،
إنه حقيقي ، إنه أمر خطير ومعظم
ما نراه يمكن الوقاية منه ،
فإن المستشفى يوفر مساحة في كل
زاوية وركن
ولكن سحق المرضى يهدد
لتطغى على الفضاء
والموظفين كل يوم ،
يتوقع الجميع هنا أن يزداد الأمر سوءًا
قبل أن يأخذ الفيروس التاجي أنفاسه الأخيرة
سارة سيدنر CNN apple Valley California